production  harris yet again tipped by simmons and b  unable to put it back balls hard to the  wood and a foul  call  and a technical has been called i  thought as well is it  yeah mitchell was just drawing too much  joelle kind enough to bring it to the  official's attention  shooter percentage-wise cashes in sixers  all over that offensive rebound  and then you can see joelle putting the  mitchell's hit to say  you're gonna put up with that give him  the t and  yep two technicals and donovan mitchell  has himself ejected here we believe in  overtime  he has not stopped talking yet he did  not like  that no call down at the other end i  thought it was  excellent blanket covering defense  by ben simmons donovan thought otherwise  ooh  knocking down and you know what yeah  that's  gonna have a look at that exactly but  but let me say this  you are locked in an overtime game it's  still very much a game and you're  getting yourself  ejected yeah